Transcriber: Leslie Gauthier
Reviewer:
Can a lack of sleep
lead to unnecessary weight gain?
Unfortunately, that’s what
the scientific evidence tells us.
[Sleeping with Science]
Part of the reason is due to an imbalance
in two key appetite-regulating hormones
called leptin and ghrelin.
Now, leptin sends a signal
of fullness to your brain,
so you feel satiated by your food.
Ghrelin, on the other hand,
does the opposite.
It sends a signal of hunger to your brain.
And sadly, these two hormones
will go in opposite directions
when we’re not getting enough sleep.
Specifically, a lack of sleep
will decrease levels of leptin,
so you won’t feel
as satisfied by your meals;
you won’t feel full.
And if that weren't bad enough,
levels of ghrelin will actually increase
when you’re not getting sufficient sleep,
so you’ll constantly feel hungry
and you’ll want to eat more.
However, it's not just that you want
to eat more when sleep gets short.
It’s also about a change
in what you want to eat.
In particular, a lack of sleep
will shift your preferences
towards desiring higher-calorie
and sugary carbohydrate foods.
What’s fascinating
is that this relationship between sleep
and food is a two-way street.
We’ve discovered that eating to excess,
and also eating a diet
that contains high amounts of sugar
and low amounts of fiber,
are all associated with significantly
worse sleep quantity
and sleep quality.
The good news here is that we can
think of sleep as a new tool
to help regulate our body weight.
And as a result,
improve our overall health
and our wellness.